thanks to us uh Jan first of all uh
welcome back to our show three victories
in a row yesterday you told Anastasia
you asked her how do you win one game in
a row now you won three Philly yeah I
had like uh
you know
I was really curious at some point like
it was uh like rapid chess I guess was
my argument strongest discipline yeah
like so I played uh really nice but okay
now my reaching print low and okay I'm
playing every almost so shiny uh so it
turns out maybe that I should also
calculate some lines you know to play
like Blitz
uh so just it's Blitz with like 25
minutes uh it's good you know
have some drawback here of getting a bad
position too early but this was always
your style right no something wasn't
working what was it no I can't say it
was my style sir I was creating a lot
all the time but okay now I became like
old and uh
lazy yeah I'm just trying to play with
hands only yeah without like any
any calculations so yeah that that's
something I try to adjust today and yeah
it worked
worked nicely but uh overall I think uh
games were not so not so great well
let's talk about this game uh against
yourself and Richie because I was
definitely impressed with your opening
knowledge like you were blitzing out
your moves and yeah and go to a bad
position
yes well actually I think I was the one
who introduced this line more or less uh
in some online online Refuge group I
guess it was like during covet or
something
uh so I knew I think it's about this
line but the age remove maybe I went for
this uh
plan wishes to ambitious yeah like uh if
white plays like Queen D2 Queen F4 Queen
H4 which which is another planet right
here then okay then you can go for 97
bhc CS6 but here other way is way more
natural yeah like okay another night but
whatever yeah uh but this bishop
frequency 2 is more natural and um I
think I'm not in time with this 96 play
but when I analyzed the position it
suddenly had a very strong move at some
point
here at what I'm doing quite nice and I
think perhaps this is yeah here I should
have taken on the fight perhaps but I
wasn't sure I have 694 I wasn't sure
about this position so 94.94 of course
yeah
uh so maybe I played a D5 second Pawn
maybe something else okay this is very
very
I don't know very unclear so
I mean surely I decided to start with
like F6 so after 9g4 I take 25 but here
was some some genius move Bishop G4
which is like hard to
I mean hard to explain why is the move
why this move is so strong but yeah just
to show something I could hear
uh we start with like take streaks
Bishop G4 here I have like a five Jake's
perhaps Jake's here and well D5 for
Bishop D7 is uh should be quite playable
yeah yeah but Bishop G4 immediately is
something I you know ah you know I'm not
ashamed to plunder
yeah but
maybe in a classical game but definitely
not in a rapid no I mean okay just this
move makes not so much sense to me but
yeah it's very strong yeah but here uh
yeah here suddenly I felt like
I had sort of an apprehension is my
place so easy but after you have to see
free I think he's nearly lost yeah yeah
perhaps with some precise play you could
like hold on but yeah this position
never always uh
I mean uh yeah he tried to sacrifice an
exchange here but I guess yeah this was
yeah once again I was like too late to
calculate so it just chopped on D5 and
this is pretty it's pretty much
technical but I'm not sure if it's
winning but it looks like very nice
chances still three out of three a
perfect day for you you're I think in a
co-leading position right now
um how do you feel confidence-wise and
how important is confidence for you and
for your type of play
uh you know it's better to be confident
or not
I guess it's uh more or less Works to
everyone in the same way uh yeah but uh
I'm more or less
you know I think it's it would be
difficult to play worse than yesterday
frankly
because I think I was lost at some point
in all three games yeah and uh
yeah and also I meet some very nice
tactics against gookish I guess
and he played the queen before it was
like our Queen C4 there was like Bishop
B5 almost winning uh yeah so I didn't
see like anything so today I think like
I played a little bit better so at least
I made some reasonable
moves yeah some nice decisions but uh
yeah it's yet
I mean it's unclear so it's one day it
was a bit one day it was good yeah so
let's see what happens tomorrow yeah
always great to have you back at your
best uh go get some rest and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you guys back to you
thank you Napa